a shock for all Deadpool fans the big
mouth mercenary was supposed to make his
comeback in May together with Wolverine
nothing will become of it however for
the time being the actors and writers
strike for better working conditions is
currently shutting down all of Hollywood
and causing chaos at the studios the
sequel Deadpool 3 was only recently
brought forward to May 3rd 2024 to the
fans Delight of course however the
enthusiasm is now likely to be dampened
Disney recently revealed their annual
overview of upcoming movies for the
period between September 2023 and June
2024 and it was not long before it
became apparent that the apparent
release date for Deadpool 3 has
surprisingly been canceled without
replacement